I mean a man doesn't attitude just
because you're having sex with him he
asked you for a lot of other reason and
doesn't matter this sex like it's not
about sex it actually adds you when it
does something wrong I don't think he
does something wrong in bed it can do
something wrong you know in any other
occasion actually probably they're gonna
be good in bed and I'm probably doing
but that's that's like a masculine trait
is not being able to bond with men
through sex because women tend to bond
with men through sex unless they've
slept with a lot of people then they
don't while we don't just think about
that a woman can enjoy sex as a man like
like you can enjoy catching feelings
that's what you like to think that's
what you like to think